你有没有这样的经历。
打开 Claude Code 或者 Cursor，跟 AI 说：帮我搭一个用户登录系统。
AI 刷刷刷就开始写，速度快得像老手。
结果四十五分钟之后你发现，它选错了方案，加了一堆没人要的功能，测试压根没跑就跟你说"全部通过"。
四十五分钟，白干。
这里是精读AI。
AI 世界很吵，每期帮你从全球顶级 AI 团队的一手文献里，读透一篇最值得读的。
今天我们精读的是 GitHub 上增长最猛的 AI 开源项目之一：Superpowers。
先说结论。
AI 写代码写砸了，问题不是它不够聪明，而是它太急了。
原作者 Jesse Vincent 是资深开源开发者，做过 RT request tracker 这样的经典项目。
他观察到一个规律：AI 编程助手有一种"病态讨好"倾向。
英文叫 pathologically eager to please。
什么意思？
打个比方。
想象你招了一个天才实习生，技术能力没话说，但是你刚开口说了半句需求，他就冲出去干活了。
干了一整天回来，方向完全反了。
你给他反馈，他秒回"你说得太对了！
"
然后立刻改，改完把之前能跑的代码也搞崩了。
这就是现在 AI 编程助手的真实状态。
它会跳过思考直接写代码。
它会伪造测试结果，告诉你一切正常。
它会对任何反馈都说"Great point"，然后盲目执行。
不是能力问题，是纪律问题。
Jesse Vincent 的解法很有意思。
他没有去造一个新框架，也没有写什么复杂的代码库。
他做了一套 Markdown 文档。
没错，就是文档。
这个项目叫 Superpowers。
它不是框架，不是代码库，是一组结构化的"技能文档"，在 AI 会话启动的时候自动注入进去，从根本上改变 AI 处理任务的方式。
你可以把它想象成新员工入职第一天收到的那本操作手册。
不是建议，不是参考，是"在这里做事就得按这个流程来，没有例外"。
项目目前包含十五个技能文档，覆盖测试、调试、协作和元流程。
每个文档里有流程图、有"合理化借口防范表"、有明确的"危险信号"清单。
这些文档不光是在教 AI 怎么做，还在提前堵住 AI 偷懒的每一条路。
它的工作原理也值得说一下。
Superpowers 支持 Claude Code、Cursor、Codex 和 OpenCode。
每次你启动一个新会话，一个 session hook 会自动触发。
你可以理解成进公司大门的门禁系统，每次开工之前，先刷一遍规章制度。
这个钩子会把核心的 using-superpowers 文档注入到 AI 的上下文里。
这份文档告诉 AI：在你回答任何问题之前，先检查有没有适用的技能文档。
哪怕只有百分之一的概率相关，你也必须调用它。
文档里有一句话是加粗大写的，原文是："IF A SKILL APPLIES TO YOUR TASK, YOU DO NOT HAVE A CHOICE. YOU MUST USE IT." 翻译过来就是：该用的技能，你没有选择权，必须用。
总结一下。
AI 编程助手最大的问题不是不会写代码，是缺少"先想后做"的纪律。
Superpowers 用十五份 Markdown 文档解决了这个问题，四个月拿下六万七千颗 GitHub 星。
下次你让 AI 写代码之前，先跟它说一句："别急，先告诉我你打算怎么做，给我两到三个方案和各自的取舍。
"就这一句话，能省掉大量返工。
那它到底怎么管住 AI 不乱写代码的？
下期聊它最狠的一招。
AI 世界很吵，精读一篇，胜过刷一百条。
我们下期再见。